President Vladimir Putin says he's open
to dialogue with Ukraine but only if
Kiev accepts that territories already
occupied by Moscow belong to Russia
Putin made those comments during a phone
call with turkey as president
called on Putin to support a unilateral
ceasefire and a fair solution the
erdogan is expected to speak to
Ukraine's Vladimir zielinski by phone
later on Thursday let's bring in a
political analyst the heavy besan he
joins us now from Istanbul via Scott
good to have you with us on Al Jazeera
again so nice to have your time I mean
what were we expecting from this float
phone call because pleasantries aside
there is a lot of serious business to be
conducted on several fronts and it all
needs to be addressed
well I think we should look at it from
the positive uh perspective which is to
say that President erdogan using his
personal uh friendship with President
Putin and actually achieving something
that many of the world leaders are not
there at all let's remember the grain
deal he he himself personally Managed IT
and 21 million tons of grain now it's
flowing in in many in the desperate
places in especially Africa North Africa
so I think this phone call extremely
important though to to to find a kind of
a viable exit strategy from this War or
conflict whatever you name it where
hundreds of and thousands of people lost
their life so it is I mean we're
expecting now uh in the afternoon as
president erdogan and like around one
hour ago in a press conference told us
that after speaking with Mr Putin this
afternoon would be speaking with Mr
zelenski to find a solution to the
conflict indeed I mean as a NATO member
uh President erdogan also has a direct
line of communication not only with the
EU and its leaders there but also with
the US how important is turkey becoming
now in this sort of trioica of trying to
speak not only to Russia and Ukraine but
also try and get messages through to
other parties other interested parties
in the conflict in Ukraine
you're absolutely right as a NATO member
turkey namely president erdogan
mediating between the two sides but I
don't think he is speaking on behalf of
NATO but nevertheless as a mediator it's
very important that both sides are
depend on him Trust on him and continue
negotiating otherwise the channels
especially like diplomatic channels
seems to be not working at all and
despite the efforts by the UN and by the
EU not much had been achieved so far but
as you said it's extremely important
that a NATO member doing it as a turkey
doing a pivotal role in to finding a
solution into this conflict but also
let's remember that President erdogan
using his personal friendship with both
leaders
bringing in solution for example
prisoners exchange or many other areas
which are extremely important at least
that channel is open and someone is
doing it willingly and this is President
erdogan himself
and of course uh president erdogan is
also as you say dealing with negotiating
those grain shipments coming out of the
Black Sea also trying to find a way to
get the two parties to talk together he
wants something out of all of this
doesn't he when he speaks to President
Putin I mean he wants President Putin
sorry President Putin yes to actually
find a solution perhaps for his pkk
problem that he sees is quite a domestic
issue for him
well it's not only domestic as such but
it's certainly also a regional issue and
very very important issue this is to say
it's not limited to pkk because I know
often the International Community turn
blind eyes to the issue but I think it's
extremely simple uh serious this is to
say that in the north eastern part of
Syria uh in the pretext of a Fight
Against Terror namely a fight against
Isis hundreds and thousands of armed man
already stationed at the Turkish border
this is I mean it's really worrying as a
Turkish citizen because these people are
armed trained financed and more
importantly gained field experience in
fighting against Isis but United States
so far does not offer any convincing
argument that what was what would happen
after uh Isis evaporates disappears
what's going to happen to these uh
people and the guns and weapons we know
other parts of the world they were just
abandoned as mission accomplished and
then the region has to deal with this so
I think turkey trying to draw attention
to this very very uh serious issue it's
not only pkk but of course turkey has
the pkk at Terror and we have you know
just recently an explosion in in the
heart of Istanbul but I think the issue
is very important an International
Community should take it uh very
seriously it's it's concerning certainly
well I think that I'd be keeping a very
close eye on in the coming days for the
moment Basin thank you so much for
joining us from istanbulse thank you